فرحه الفرنسيين في استقبال عيد الميلاد
هذا العام تعكرها ازمه الطاقه فبينما كانت
اضواء الزينه سابقا تملا الشوارع في كل
مكان باتت الاولويه اليوم لتوفير الطاقه
هنا في جده اصبحت اضواء الزينه التي تكسو
400 شجره تطفئ قبل حوالي ساعتين من موعدها
اليوم ستنزع قبل اسبوعين من موعدها
المعتاد الهدف هو تخفيض استهلاك الطاقه
هذه السنه بما يعادل اكثر من 40%
في همم يمكننا تحمل قطع الكهرباء ساعتين
يوميا في البيوت لكن ليست التخلي عن اضواء
الزينه هنا هذا الاجراء الهادف للحد من
استهلاك الطاقه خلال فتره الاعياد لا
يقتصر على العاصمه بل يمتد الى بقيه المدن
الفرنسيه مرسيليا مثلا اعتمدت اضواء زينه
قليله التكلفه وصديقه للبيئه
بالنجوم فالاضاءه تنعكس عليهما نحتاج الى
صنع الاحلام في الحياه لكن هناك من يحاول
تحطيمها لم تغرب مظاهر الاحتفال بعيد
الميلاد عن شوارع المدن الفرنسيه لكنها
تاثرت بشكل كبير في القرى الصغيره التي
اضطرت في معظم الحالات للتخلي عنها كليا
او استبدالها باناره الشوارع زينه عادي
العربي العربيه باريس